if you could redo anything about your
20s oh my god what would it be
who would he be okay it's like that
would be my head I'm going to feltro and
here we are for BuzzFeed with Jessica
Alba we're giving life advice you're
gonna live by all of this advice how do
you start off each morning I am
Karia really yeah I have two different
starts of the morning because I go
through phases of exercising and phases
of not exercising so my phases of
exercising as I wake up early and I go
to the gym when I'm still blurry-eyed
but I always take like a tea so I'm
drinking that to try and wake up on the
way to the gym I sweat it out for 45
minutes I come home by the time the kids
are waking up so that's the way Liam
it's early but that's the only way I can
like see them then go to work and do how
long's do your workout phases last
before you labs uh sometimes it's if you
make sometimes fifty months actually
yeah how do you motivate yourself to
work out after a long exhausting day
when I first met the trainer that I've
been with for ever and ever I had just
had my son like maybe ten months before
and I could not lose like the last bit
of weight and it was very demoralizing
and I wasn't like seeing change and and
I said to her one morning like I really
really don't want to do this like I
can't I don't want to and she said to me
stop even stop giving yourself that
option she's like do you say to yourself
like I don't want to brush my teeth
she's like you just brush them and she's
like you're you were just doing this and
it kind of changed the way that I
perceived it so I took the optionality
out of it and I was like I just do it
and then and then it wasn't like oh like
rolling a boulder up a hill like it
wasn't an option it wasn't an option
part of your life like you brush your
teeth
take a shower you work out like it's not
right
I don't feel like it today what is one
beauty secret or tip that's changed your
life
when I dye my hair which isn't often but
when I do I sleep with oil and leave-in
conditioner in my hair most nights Oh
before you die or after after after
what's one thing every woman should do
in their 20s I feel like every woman
should live in Manhattan in their 20s
that's a really really good even if it's
just a short time but I think it's a
great thing to do I would have loved to
have the opportunity to kind of start my
self exploration earlier in my 20s I was
really I feel like I really had my head
up my ass until I was about 38 do you
believe in soulmates mm you do believe
in soulmates how do you imagine it's
weird you know I did when I was younger
and then I got really um I don't know I
just didn't
after my first breakup and then when I
met my husband I felt like I had known
in my whole life the day I met him he
was very familiar and he felt like
family what's the best piece of advice
you've ever been given that you keep
with you to this day my dad gave me the
best advice like pertaining to every
situation in my 20s I was having trouble
with one of my girlfriends who like you
know known since grade school
you can't make new old friends and it
really stuck with me and now that's
actually a piece of ice think you can
apply it to other things too but it's
like the value in time you know it's
sort of like what you were saying with
cash like the value that's created when
two people make a commitment whether
it's a relationship or a friendship or a
parent-child relationship to commit to
the commitment is very powerful it is
very powerful I think people who come
from my kind of background feel like
certain things aren't meant for you
because your circumstance is different
and my mom was always like you can have
absolutely anything you want in this
world if you work hard it's true and so
that stuck with me from day one oh yeah
I feel like I always learn something
when I sit next to her I know me too
like you always are surprising in the
best way with your answers it was nice
to hear about your what you just said
about your mom
you know what I think is great about the
show that we that we did is a were not
reality TV folks obviously people get to
see aside to Gweneth and I got to see
and learn a side to her that she's so
freakin smart but so emotionally
intelligent and I think that's something
that you can't really learn you either
have it or you don't
I haven't seen a lot of actresses that
have been emotionally intelligent in
this way and I really appreciate it
and so it's cool thank you
anyway I need to go and Buzz here on my
trip in fact it's really fun my son
yesterday was doing something that he
learned on BuzzFeed and I remember what
it was
[Music]